so let's stick with this idea the
simplification that there's a gene for
eye color and it only comes with two
variants has it has the dominant variant
which is which codes for brown eye color
and it has the
recessive variant which codes for blue
eye color so if you have any of if
either one of your alleles is this
capital b you're going to have brown
eyes the only way to have blue eyes is
to have a lower case is to have is to be
homozygous for the recessive allele
now let's say that in a population it's
a large population one that meets all of
the the heart the hardy weinberg
equilibrium
assumptions let's say that you were to
observe that nine percent of this
population has
blue eyes
so now we're talking about the phenotype
you can actually observe that they have
blue eyes so based on this can we figure
out can we figure out
p which is the frequency of the dominant
allele can we figure this out and can we
figure out q which is the frequency of
the recessive allele can we figure that
out as well and i encourage you to pause
this video and figure and based on what
we saw of the hardy-weinberg equation
can we figure these things out given
this information
well let's revisit the hardy weinberg
equation we've worked it out in previous
video but i'll rewrite it right now
it says the allele frequency for the
dominant the the dominant allele
frequency squared plus two times the
dominant allele frequency times the
recessive allele frequency
plus the recessive allele frequency
squared is equal to one and we saw that
this just comes from the idea that p
plus q is going to be equal to one
there's a hundred percent chance if you
were to randomly pick a gene that it's
one of these two
one of these two variants
now when you say nine percent has blue
eyes what does that mean well in order
the only way to have blue eyes is if
your genotype
is
homozygous recessive because if you have
a capital b in here then you're going to
have brown eyes so we can say that nine
percent also has this genotype
or you could say that the frequency in
the population of this genotype is nine
percent
but we've already seen that's exactly
that's exactly what this term right over
here is that's this q squared term this
is the probability one way to think
about it of getting of this is the q of
course is the frequency of the recessive
allele now this is the you could view
this as the probability of getting two
of the recessive alleles is going to be
if you're in your population it's going
to be nine percent so we could say q
squared is equal to nine percent or
another way to think about it this term
right over here is nine percent or
0.09
0.09 that's what this
nine percent has this genotype that's
what this tells us right over here so
then we can solve for q if q squared
i'll write it as a decimal 0.09 that
means that q is going to be the square
root of 0.09
which is equal to
0.3
so just like that we were able to figure
out the allele frequency of the
recessive allele 30 and i could write
that as a percentage 0.3 or 30 percent
if you look at the genes in the
population 30 percent express our code
code for the recessive allele or the are
the recessive variant
and so based on that we can figure out
what percentage code for the dominant
variant the rest of the the rest of the
genes must code for the domino because
we're assuming there's only two of them
p plus q equal a hundred percent or p
plus p plus q is equal to one so this
must be
seventy percent so just based on that we
can all we can we can kind of dig a
little bit deeper here so what is p
squared p squared is going to be 70
squared or 0.7 squared so this right
over here is 0.7 squared which is
0.49 so one way to think about it is
based on this and once again a simple
equation but these really neat ideas are
starting to pop out of it based on just
this information we're now able to say
that 49 of the population is going to be
is going to have a genotype of capital b
capital b they're going to be homozygous
dominant
and then we can figure out this right
over here 2 times p times q that's going
to be
times 0.7
times
0.7 times 0.3 times
0.3 so let's see that's going to be 2
times 2 times 0.21 so this is going to
be
this right over here is going to be 0.42
or another way to think about it is 42
percent of this population is going to
have the genotype uppercase b and
lowercase b and you see they all add up
49 plus 42 percent is 91 percent plus
percent all adds up to one all adds up
to a hundred percent so you get a little
bit of information here and based on
what we know about allele frequencies
making a few assumptions we're able to
get a lot more knowledge about this
population and this could this is
actually very useful in real life
when people think about
say a recessive allele that might cause
some type of a disease based on based on
the incidence of that disease people can
start to think about what percentage of
the population is a carrier say there
are heterozygotes for that disease so
this is actually very useful in real
life